- Nice to meet you.
- It's nice to meet you too.
- Have you met before?
- No.
- No, but we both love
"Real Housewives".
- Oh, I love.
- So we're gonna do
a whole deep dive later on,
I'm certain of it.
- Okay, okay,
- Oh my gosh,
- you're both into that.
- for sure.
- This is, unfortunately,
one of those moments where
you're meeting your absolute biggest fan.
And I'm gonna be sort of, like,
(Kelly laughs)
when you were with Meryl
on the Golden Globes.
- Oh, my God,
- I hope that doesn't
- I made a complete
- make you nervous,
- idiot of myself.
but I have stats.
I have seen you
in concert 13 times.
- (mockingly) I have stats.
- What?
(Chloë gasps)
- [Chloë] Wow.
(audience applauds and cheers)
- 13.
- What, I love you.
- No.
- I didn't know this.
- You don't know, ever since-
- I knew a little,
'cause I have a video I wanna show
that I thought was amazing.
- Well, yeah, I've done my research.
Honestly, like,
(Kelly guffaws)
it goes all the way back, like,
- Oh.
- I think it was,
obviously, 2002.
You were on American Idol,
as we all know.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, uh-huh. And truly-
- I don't know if
everyone knows that, like-
- (shrilly) What, no.
(Kelly laughs)
All of America
knows their Idol, I think.
(Kelly and Chloë laugh)
If they don't, come on people.
- There's a bunch of us.
- (laughs) That's true.
What is it, like,
16, 17 of them now?
- There's a lot of us now.
- You might be the most memorable.
No shade.
- No, I'll just, you know,
I'll just take it that way.
- Yeah, okay.
- I'll filter it that way.
- No shade, applause.
(audience applauds)
(Kelly laughs)
(Chloë and Kelly laughing)
No, but, like, it was.
You, actually,
mean a lot to me,
because it was, like, 2002,
like I said, I think I
realized I was gay, like,
11, 12 years old. (Kelly and
Chloë make positive noises)
That happened
and then I remember it was just
seeing you on TV
and watching everyone
fall in love with you for just,
what it seemed like,
effortlessly being yourself
and being so talented.
- Oh.
- And that was just such a, like,
driving force for me.
- Oh, you're so nice.
(audience applauds)
- No, I mean,
all my friends at home are watching, like,
"Matt, don't cry, don't do
it." (Chloë gasps theatrically)
- Don't lose your. (laughs)
- 'Cause I've had
the opportunity to meet you, like,
three times and I'll get, like,
four steps towards you
and I'll be like, "Nope.".
- Really?
- It can't happen.
- And on the "Kelly Clarkson Show"
- Wait, did you-
- you have to meet you.
- You're forced
- They do.
- It's sort of the vibe.
- This is a forced fun.
(Matt laughs)
Forced fun.
- It actually, like...
It's funny,
'cause I remember being, like,
truly 12, 13 years old
and you remember how, like,
in middle school you'd
have to fill out those
get to know you cards
when you get to a new class?
- Yep.
- So it was like, "What's
your favorite color?",
"What's your favorite food?",
"Who's your favorite singer?".
- Yeah.
- And, like I said,
I was very closeted,
and so I felt like
if I put Kelly Clarkson on there,
they'd be like, "Gay.".
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh, Matt.
- But, and so-
- That's so true.
- And so I'm from Long Island.
It was, like,
and so I was, like,
I feel like I had to fit in.
- Yeah.
- So who I would put
for my favorite singer
was always Limp Bizkit.
(Chloë gasps)
- What.
- Oh, my God,
you went, like, so, like, hetero.
- I went all the way hetero.
- Yeah.
- And it's no offense to Fred Durst
and his girls.
- No.
- That he had soul.
- You didn't pick poorly.
- No.
- I just love
that you went very hetero.
- Well, because it was, like,
panic, panic, panic.
- Yeah.
- It was like, "How do I seem like
(deeply) the straightest guy in class?".
(Kelly laugh)
- "Limp Bizkit".
- And I was like, "Limp Bizkit".
And then I remember-
- You didn't wanna put
"A Moment Like This"?
(Kelly laughs)
- [Chloë] Aww.
"A Moment Like This"?
- Well, then I remember,
like...
- I love you.
- Oh, there's me,
that should give you an idea.
- Oh, my God.
- That doesn't look a human face.
- In an Abercrombie ad.
- I really wish this guy
would've put
- Oh, my God.
"A Moment Like This" down.
- Cheers.
- Okay, wait,
I should've let you welcome
us back from the break,
'cause this is the video I did catch.
This is on your TikTok.
- Oh, shoot.
(whooshing)
- Welcome back to the "Kelly
Clarkson Show", y'all.
Give it up for the porg from Star Wars.
(Matt wooing in video)
Yo, my next guest is a singer and dancer
and she's crazy.
Everyone give it up for Madonna, y'all.
(Matt wooing in video)
(whooshing)
- [Chloë] That is so good.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience applauds and laughs)
- You said (wooing).
(Chloë wooing mockingly)
- Okay,
first of all, I mean,
what I missed,
in my impression of you was,
(shrill southern drawl) "Give
it up for my band, y'all".
(Kelly laughs)
- Yeah.
- Which I really should
have thrown in there.
And by the way-
- Yeah, look at my band, yeah.
- I have to tell you
I'm such a huge fan.
I'm, like, gagged to meet Jason.
- Oh, my gosh,
you are a big fan!
- I can't believe it.
- Oh, my god, I love that.
- No, I'm number one.
But, like, literally,
you know what's funny
is that thing of you is a coaster.
That's a coaster with your face on it.
And so one year-
- (laughS) I've made it
- Christmas gift hack.
- For sure.
- So one year it was, like,
deep in the pandemic, like,
the 2020 Christmas.
- Yeah.
- I, as a gift for all my friends,
I got coasters with the person
that they stand on them.
- Oh, my God.
- So it was, like,
I drove around like a little gay Santa.
I was like, "Here's your coasters.".
It was, like, my friend, Gus,
got, like, Patti LuPone.
- Yeah.
My friend, Lewis,
got Madonna.
My friend, Mac, got Beyonce
and I got some Kelly Clarkson coasters.
- I love it.
- For myself.
- [Kelly] For myself.
I love it, wait,
I have to get to you at some point.
Wait, you're being so nice.
- [Matt] At some point,
we can keep talking about you, though.
So, wait, so speaking of the holidays
your special is called,
"Have You Heard of Christmas?".
- Yes, It's called "Have
You Heard of Christmas?".
And if you haven't it's a huge holiday.
(all laughing)
It's one of the biggest.
- [Chloë] Oh my God.
- Chlo.
- [Chloë] I'm telling you.
- I'm telling you it's major.
And so, as you and I know,
in every pop star's life
there comes a time when you decide
to make a Christmas album.
- I wanted to make one,
like, year one, for me.
- Yes, absolutely.
- I love Christmas music.
- No, it's the best.
- Yeah.
- But, you sort of are
an established pop star, we'd say.
I'm not, yet.
(Kelly laughing)
- [Chloë] Oh, my God.
- When you watch my
special on December 2nd
you're gonna understand.
This man deserves to be
in the Christmas cannon.
I'm trying to be the Prince of Christmas.
(audience cheering)
- Like Mariah's the Queen.
- Like Mariah is the Queen
of Christmas.
- Yes, yes, I get it.
- The Prince.
- And so,
this special is a documentation
of me trying to realize that.
So we'll see how it goes.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh,
I'm excited about this.
- That is so good.
- It's fun, I'm really excited about it.
I've toured it for years.
I'm actually going out on the road
and doing 15 cities with it all
throughout December.
- So it's something you've
already kind of had for years,
but you're now putting
in a Christmas special
on TV for everybody to get part of.
- Yeah, so, I remember watching
an interview with Mariah
Carey, like, years ago
and the interviewer was like,
"It's so amazing how you thought
to make a Christmas album,
'cause now you're relevant every year."
And every year she gets bigger,
and I'm sitting there just, like,
a comedian in New York, like,
"I'm interested in that.".
(Kelly laughing)
I'm interested in seasonal ubiquity.
(Kelly and Chloë laughing)
I think I'm making a Christmas album.
- I could make this.
And then I just,
I wrote an original Christmas album
with my musical director,
- I love that.
- Who's actually my ex-boyfriend.
So that gets explored in the show as well.
- Whoa.
(Kelly laughing)
Saucy.
- Yeah, it's kinda saucy.
I keep it close.
(Kelly and Chloë laughing)
- (laughs) I'm not great
at the (indistinct).
- Boundaries, there are none.
- Oh, so we could talk.
- Yeah.
- But, anyway,
we wrote an entirely original
comedy Christmas album and,
- Yeah.
- Yeah,
I'm super excited about it.
- That's so cool.
- Yeah.
- I love that.
All right, let's do another break.
Matt's special is called,
"Matt Rogers, Have You
Heard of Christmas?"
It premieres Friday,
December 2nd on Showtime.